El Salvador's been living under a state
of emergency for almost five months to
tackle the country's rampant gang
violence this week it was extended
further 50
000 people have so far been detained
that's just under two percent of the
country's labor force President naibu
Kelly calls them all terrorists
under the emergency measures those
detainees haven't got the right to a
lawyer or to be informed why they've
been arrested
human rights groups say that many are
processed in Mass hearings in which
evidence isn't usually presented
renas has her husbands among them my
husband was working and I didn't find
out he was detained until 10 pm
the Congress dominated by the ruling
party overwhelmingly voted for the
measures to continue
[Applause]
the president of El Salvador and his
government will do everything that is
required to guarantee that these 50 000
gang members will be captured and the
rest will not put a foot inside our
communities
and why not the state of exception is
widely popular among an electorate
exhausted and traumatized by Decades of
predatory gangs
an association of bus companies has said
that extortion among its members has
dropped by 95 percent
the president the architect of the
Crackdown regularly tweets that the
country is seeing days of zero murders
as a result of it
but at what price Amnesty International
says that dozens of people have died in
custody
and under past crackdowns the gangs have
simply re-emerged again at the end
the government bats away those concerns
and lambasts its critics it says it's at
War and will win John Holman Al Jazeera